[Music]
[Music]
welcome back
okay in the last lecture we derived the
wave equation for a vibrating guitar
string
uh from scratch from f equals ma physics
um literally just you know conservation
of momentum of a little infinitesimal
section of guitar string
vibrating up and down you know being
forced by its own tension essentially
the tension in the string so we derived
this equation from scratch
where the wave speed c is related to the
material properties of the guitar string
c is literally the square root of the
tension divided by the linear density
so increasing the tension increases the
wave speed which makes higher pitched
sounds decreasing the tension makes it
lower pitched i massively detuned my
guitar last time but it's back to in
tune
and the linear density a thicker string
a thicker heavier string like the low e
will have a
lower wave speed because it has a higher
row
than a thinner lighter
high e string
right so this one the low one
has a bigger row smaller c the lighter
one has a smaller row higher c and that
translates to either a lower pitch sound
or a higher pitched sound
so what we're going to do today is from
this uh wave equation we're now going to
solve this for some specific boundary
conditions literally for this guitar
boundary condition where it's pinned
uh kind of here
and here at the at the bridge and at the
neck
and then we're going to analyze what
happens you know to this wave equation
what happens what are the solutions of
this wave equation and how does that
translate into intuitive things we know
you know from from music from sound from
things like that okay
uh so that's all coming up but we're
going to solve this using separation of
variables one of the most important
solution techniques for partial
differential equations
um i want to point out just uh i hope
you appreciate i
hike i hiked
my guitar up three miles from home to to
film today so i hope you appreciate uh
the dedication i thought about just
playing air guitar but i figured this
would be a lot more interesting
just uh
preface at the very beginning you know i
am a complete amateur
novice i know zero music theory my wife
likes to joke that you know all i know
is string theory for the wave equation
and the string i don't really know any
music theory
but i do think uh that this is a really
intuitive kind of example
because
music much like mathematics i think
resonates very much with the
kind of
logical
part of our brain but we also know when
it feels right and so that meeting place
of kind of
thought and feeling i think is very much
shared between mathematics
and music
and in fact there are deep deep
connections between music and
mathematics that people have been
exploring and uncovering for hundreds of
years for centuries
if not millennia so even if you go back
this is a little bit of a just a history
digression but i think it's interesting
if you go back uh to you know tico bray
and kepler before um
galileo before newton before we knew
about f equals ma and before we had you
know proven that the the sun was the
center of the solar system when things
were still speculative and people didn't
understand why the planets behave the
way that they did
there was a theory and kepler held on
very strongly to this theory that there
were harmonic patterns in the motion of
the planets and the motion of the stars
just like musical patterns and layers
uh you know the defined musical
composition they believed that there
were these patterns in the stars and the
heavens and the planets and that that
musical composition was perhaps divine
and definitely had an impact in our
daily lives right this is astrology
um
you know from the olden days it always
had this flavor of you know
one part mathematics and one part music
just fascinating i think
oh and uh yeah in in lugging uh my
guitar to work today i was thinking back
a friend of mine taught me a new word
called busking so busking is when you
bring your your guitar or musical
instrument and you play in public
in a public space
and i think it's a super fun busking uh
comes from the spanish word uh buskar
which means to seek you know to seek out
or something and so we are all you know
in some sense busking and buskers
because we're all seeking
uh seeking knowledge this is a very very
meta you know two steps removed online
youtube version of busking i suppose
okay good so i'm going to jump right
into this um
we're going to solve this equation using
separation of variables
uh maybe i'll just write it here
separation of variables
which we've already seen
before when we solve laplace's equation
for the heat distribution in a
rectangular metal plate
here we're going to solve for uh kind of
you know the the vibration the motion of
the string where it's pinned in two
locations at x equals zero and x equals
l l is the length of my string
and so again for a partial differential
equation to be well defined we need to
define its boundary conditions and its
initial condition so i'm going to do
that here i'm going to say just to be
very very clear
u
of x and t
is the height of the spur of the string
the height
or kind of the height or the
displacement of that string the
displacement of the string
and it's going to be a function of x the
position along the string and in time
it's going to be oscillating in space
and in time
and our boundary conditions our boundary
conditions
are essentially u
at x equals zero
for all of time is going to equal zero
so we've essentially pinned the string
in one position up at the
up at the neck and that is going to be a
zero displacement for all time this is
at the at the neck
and similarly at the bridge at the at
the other end of the string u of sorry
it's so squeaky
um
is also equal to zero so at length l for
all time it's also pinned in that
location but it can kind of do whatever
it wants in the middle okay so i can i
can you know deflect the string you know
i can pull the string with my finger and
make it a little
shallow triangle
uh that's totally fine as long as it
stays pinned at both of the boundaries
and then the last thing i need is my
initial condition maybe i'll switch
colors so it's not so squeaky oh still
squeaky
my initial condition is going to be u at
x at time zero so now my remember my
boundary conditions are for all time
at spatial boundaries
my initial condition is at a given time
at my initial time t 0
at all
of the positions x i'm just going to
define the displacement at time 0
to be some function
of x and this function of x could be
you know that i take my guitar string
and i
you know essentially pull up on the
guitar string in one place and then i
let it go that could be my f of x is
that it's this little triangle from me
pulling up you know and about to with my
pick or with my finger
so i have boundary conditions and
initial conditions which make this a
well-posed partial differential equation
it's a linear partial differential
equation
which means that superposition holds it
means that if i have you know multiple
solutions and i add them up if i have
multiple solutions that satisfy my
boundary conditions and i add them up
then
they're still going to be a solution of
my partial differential equation that's
nice
and we're going to solve this using
separation of variables just like we did
before so i'm gonna i'm gonna jump in
so our separation of variables
assumption the basic basic assumption
here
is that um
u
of x and t
my function of space and time
is separate is separable which means
that i can write this as a product of a
function just of x
f of x
times a function g that's just a
function of time
so this is the basic basic assumption of
separation of variables is that i can
say that my solution which varies in
space and time remember that that guitar
string is vibrating in space and in time
but i'm going to assume this is an
assumption that it can be written as a
product of a function just of space
times a function just of time
and when we plug this into our pde and
go through all of the steps we're going
to see if that assumption holds and if
we can get a solution that satisfies
these boundary conditions and initial
conditions
good
uh so so that's what we're gonna do
and maybe i will
just start writing out what the
derivatives are i think that's a good
place to start we're going to plug it
into this pde so we need to be able to
compute u t t and u x x pretty simple
so uh u t
t
is just the second partial derivative of
this with respect to time so that's you
know f of x
times g double prime
t
good
and similarly u x x
is f double prime x
times g of t pretty pretty simple stuff
here
okay
and because we know that um
u t equals c squared u x x i can use
these expressions
to essentially say
that
f x
g double prime t
equals c squared
f double prime x
g of t
okay
uh
good
and so now just like uh
we've done in the past what we're going
to do is we're going to collect all of
the functions of x on one side and all
the functions of g on the other side
and we're going to try to turn those
into ordinary differential equations
just of x and just of t okay so we're
going to try to take this
spatial temporal problem this this
function of two variables x and t and
break it down into you know just a
problem in x and just a problem in t
that we can solve using our kind of
basic ode
uh technology that we are very
comfortable with
okay and i always forget you know where
i should keep my c should i keep my
constant on the x terms or on the
um
on the time terms i think i'm going to
keep
the
[Music]
i think i'm going to move my c's over so
i think what i'm going to do is i'm
going to
say i have f double prime of x
over f
of x i'm going to divide both sides by f
i'm going to divide both sides by g
and i'm going to divide both sides by c
squared so this equals one over c
squared
g double prime t
over g of t
you can you know pause the video slow it
down whatever but all i've done is i've
divided both sides by
f double prime by g double prime and
divided by c squared so that the c
squared is now with my functions of time
and this is where um in the last you
know video where i did separation of
variables for laplace's equation i made
a really big point of emphasizing that
if i have a function that's just a
function of x
and i have a function that's just a
function of time and they equal each
other then they both have to be equal to
a constant
this has to equal some
some k some you know
i should not spell constant with a k but
this is a constant okay this is a
constant
k
okay so
[Music]
and that's again because this is just a
function of x and this is just a
function of t and for those to be equal
to each other it has to equal some
constant
k
and you know maybe what i'll do because
i you know that these are going to be
eigenvalues i'm just going to call that
constant k
some constant lambda okay
uh some some constant lambda and in fact
i'm going to make it lambda squared
because i know it's going to be a
positive constant we'll we'll get there
maybe maybe i'll just call it lambda
good
so
i should point out okay i'll i'll do you
know the next step is going to be
solving
you know
just taking f double prime x over f
equals lambda and solving that ordinary
differential equation in x
uh you know presumably with these
boundary conditions and then doing the
same thing for the time ordinary
differential equation and then combining
those that's what we do in separation of
variables
i'll point out um
you know i i mentioned in the last video
that the wave equation is something i
actually don't usually dive too much
into depth uh in my class um it's
something you know i've spent a lot of
time
uh over the years
contemplating the wave equation it's
never been my favorite pde that i felt
really really comfortable with it's
super important it's everywhere
and over the last few days i have just
been you know wandering around
uh like a
planet planet means wanderer so i've
just been wandering around
um you know listening to guitar music
and thinking about
the wave equation and its solution and
when i derived this out as kind of a
test run of this video
i got all the signs wrong my c's were
all in the wrong place so i just want
you to know that if it looks like uh
well if it goes really smoothly it
didn't the first time and if it doesn't
go very smoothly uh you are forewarned
okay this is the kind of thing you've
got to be really careful
uh to keep track of the signs and where
the seas are and all of that stuff and
for me personally the only way i can
keep track of it
is to have some idea of the physical
intuition of what i want my solution to
look like so maybe before i solve this
i'm going to just go back to the physics
here
we have a guitar string that's pinned in
two places at the you know one condition
x equals zero and another x equals l
l the length of the string
the only solutions that can satisfy
those two boundary conditions
essentially have to be sine waves that
have you know a period of l something
like sine of you know uh
x pi over l or sine of
2 pi x over l or 3 pi x over l or 4 pi x
over l those are the only you know basic
solutions that can satisfy these two
boundary conditions
um and so i kind of already know
that my functions of x my f of x are
going to be signs with that period
and so that's going to help me figure
out should my lambda be positive or
negative you know things like that so
um
let's hope i get it right if i don't
we'll fix it good
so now what we're going to do so step
zero essentially was you know the basic
assumption of separation of variables
uh step
one
is you know computing all of the
derivatives and getting to this point
here so step one is computing all these
derivatives and kind of arriving at
this basic um
expression here
and now step two i'm gonna break it up
into two parts i'm gonna solve the ode
for the functions of x and i'm gonna
solve the ode for the functions of time
so uh
and let's call this 2a because there's
two parts to this
what i want to point out
is i always want to pick the one that's
easiest to solve first where i have more
information
and if you notice here it looks like my
boundary conditions are pretty simple i
have you know fixed pinned boundary
conditions at x equals zero and x equals
l and so i'm pretty sure my functions of
space are going to be sine waves with
that length l period
so i think that it's going to be easier
to solve these f equations first and
then once that determines uniquely what
this constant is again this constant is
going to determine be determined somehow
by this length l
once i determine what that constant is
and what these solutions are then i can
solve for
how those vary in time so i'm going to
start with my functions f that's just
generally speaking a good idea to start
with the easy stuff first
and so here we have an equation that's
something like
um
you know f
double prime
x
over f of x
equals uh maybe i will call this
uh lambda squared but i think i think
i remember what
issue i had when i was deriving this a
couple of days ago is that i
am used to this constant being positive
this lambda squared and when i used a
positive constant here let's let's say
this is lambda squared when i used a
positive constant
i got the wrong
solutions to this ordinary differential
equation i'm looking for sines and
cosines in x and i think i got like
exponential functions
uh
in x which is not right
and so i i had to remind myself that
this could be a negative constant this
this constant that both of these
equal this can totally be a negative
constant
so this is going to make my life a lot
easier
and i think what you what you should do
for those of you at home
is
you should try this for a positive
constant and work out what those
solutions f of x are and convince
yourself that you can't possibly satisfy
these boundary conditions with the
exponential functions you get with a
positive lambda squared
but when you use negative lambda squared
we're going to get sines and cosines out
which make it so we can
satisfy these boundary conditions so i'm
kind of skipping a couple of minutes of
uh
you know existential crisis for you and
we're just going to you know use the
prior knowledge i had that this should
probably be a negative constant
but you could figure this out yourself
this this constant at this point is
completely undetermined it can be
anything you like
and i'm using lambda squared because
this is a second order equation and it's
just going to be easier to to have it be
lambda squared you could just call this
some constant k
and work it all out yourself
okay so what we have here and we're just
going to switch back to yellow
is that we have f double prime
plus lambda squared f equals 0.
and since this is this is not a partial
differential equation this is an
ordinary differential equation it has
one independent variable x
and so this
this ordinary differential equation is
easy to solve we know how to solve
second order linear differential
equations this is essentially the
equation for a
mass on a spring and this lambda
squared is the square of that spring
frequency the frequency of oscillation
so that's again why i needed this to be
negative so that when i multiplied f and
added it i got a spring equation that
has a plus and minus i omega eigenvalue
okay
and so essentially we know
that this is going to have solutions
f of x
equals
and how do i want to write this this is
going to have f
of x
equals
some constant i'll call it you know
alpha
cosine
of
[Music]
lambda x
plus some other constant beta
sine
lambda x
okay good so this is just what happens
when you solve this differential
equation you get a cosine and a sine
component
again you can go back to your kind of
basic linear
ordinary differential equations to solve
this
this is the solution
and what we know
is that the only way that this
this function f can satisfy both
boundary conditions being zero
at x equals zero and x equals l
is essentially you know cosine is not
going to be ever zero at x equals zero
so the only way we can solve this is to
have the alpha
all of these terms equal to zero no
cosine part because cosine of zero is
always equal to one
okay so it can't satisfy this left
boundary condition unless alpha is zero
and the only way that sine of lambda x
can satisfy this boundary condition
is if
lambda
equals
pi
over l
times some integer n
where n you know equals one two three
dot dot dot it could also equal zero um
let's put zero in there it could be zero
one two three dot dot dot it could also
be negative one negative two negative
three that's all fine
but the only way that this can satisfy
the zero boundary conditions that x
equals zero and x equals l
is if lambda equals pi over l times some
integer okay and so essentially what we
get
is that f of x f of x equals
uh let's just call this um
beta n because there's going to be a
constant for every integer n
beta n
sine
of
n
pi over l
times x
uh where you know lambda equals
pi over l
pi over l times times n okay good so we
have solved kind of half of our ordinary
differential equation so we've solved
the functions of x
the only way they can satisfy these
boundary conditions
is for very particular lambda remember
special values are eigenvalues so these
lambda are eigenvalues of this ordinary
differential equation
f double prime x
plus lambda squared f of x equals zero
this ordinary differential equation has
eigenvalues plus and minus i lambda
and that gives cosine of lambda x plus
sine of lambda x type solutions
the signs are the only ones that can
satisfy the pinned boundary conditions
here and they can only satisfy it for
very special lambda for very special
values so that that sign is equal to
zero at x equals zero
that that's true for any lambda but for
it to be equal to zero at x equals l
then lambda l sine of lambda l has to
equal zero and that has to be sine of
lambda l
uh you know has to be some integer
multiple of pi okay and so essentially
this is the solution for all the
functions in x
good and so we've done two super
important things here in this step we
have determined that the only spatial
solutions to this uh partial
differential equation can only be built
out of sine functions
in x
and we've also determined out of all of
the possible constants that these could
equal
lambda has to be a very very special
constant an eigenvalue constant given by
a pi n over l where n is an integer and
l is the length of my string so we've
determined that our eigenvalue has to be
pi n over l to satisfy these boundary
conditions and that our functions of of
x are signs you know with that frequency
good
so that was believe it or not that was
the easy part and now for 2b we're going
to solve the same equations in g for the
temporal dynamics for these g of t
coefficients here
so let's do that
and i actually this one's not going to
be super hard now i just want to make
sure i give myself space to do it
so maybe i'll just do it right here
so for 2b
we're going to be solving now my
g equations which are going to be
something like
uh
g double prime
equals
minus
c squared lambda squared g
okay
and if i rewrite this i can say that
that's g double prime
plus c squared lambda squared g
pretty simple okay
and now this is kind of nice because
okay this is this equals zero
this is basically the same type of
equation this is also an ordinary
differential equation that has
the same form as a mass on a spring and
now instead of the frequency being
lambda the frequency is c times lambda
here okay so similarly my g of ts
are going to be equal to some you know
some other constants i don't know what
to call these um
let's call them uh
i don't know k
um
times
cosine
of c lambda t
plus some other constant c times sine
of c lambda t
okay
good
now um
we can essentially
fix this lambda we know what lambda
equals it's pi n over l so this is you
know c times pi times n over l times t
that's going to be uh like the frequency
of how this string is oscillating in
time and again if i pluck a guitar
string it's generating acoustic waves
based on its oscillating frequency so
this frequency here
is going to be directly tied to the
frequency that i hear when i pluck a
guitar string so it's going to depend on
you know this c
and on this lambda which is a function
of the length of the string
and n which are the harmonics so we'll
get to harmonics in a minute
and so now how do i figure out
if this is cosine or sine or some
combination and i think what i would
argue
is that because this thing starts with
an initial condition
u of x comma zero at time t equals zero
i'm really only considering the cosine
portion of this
because sine of c lambda t is equal to 0
at time 0. so i'm only going to use the
cosine portion of this to determine my
to satisfy my initial conditions
so i'm only going to be looking at this
portion
and i'm going to explicitly plug in my
lambda here and i'm going to say this
equals
um
you know i've got my cosine
of
n of n pi
c
over l
t
and this constant k i'm gonna say that
there are n of these constants for every
integer n for each of these lambda
n uh for each of these lambda n
there is a constant outside of that that
cosine
good and if you like um
this this constant is basically going to
be determined by uh this fourier
transform here so i'll get back to that
in a minute
okay so this actually ended up being
simple now that i had fixed this lambda
from my functions of x i use that lambda
in my functions of in my ordinary
differential equation for my function of
time i solve it out i get that it also
is sines and cosines and the only way
i'm going to be able to satisfy this
about this initial condition at time 0
is through these cosine components
that i have here
and so now if i combine these two
equations i essentially get my answer
which is
let's see if i can not botch this it
should be pretty simple
u
of x and t remember it's the product of
all of these
for every n for each integer n it's the
product of this sine
and this cosine
and i add up all of those solutions for
all n because this is a linear pde so
all of those solutions are solutions and
when you add them up it's still a
solution
so this is equal to the sum
uh let's say from n equals you know
zero to infinity
of and i'm gonna just combine these two
constants my beta n and my k n i'm gonna
multiply these together so it's just
some constant n
of you know sine
n
pi over l x
times cosine
n pi c over l t
and this is
the solution
of
my wave equation that was the worst
star
i've ever drawn so this is the solution
of my wave equation so u of x and t the
the the displacement at every point x at
every point time
is given by this infinite sum of the
products of sines in x that satisfy my
boundary conditions
and cosines in time and if you like what
we're gonna do the way that we determine
these coefficients is we pin
we use our initial condition we say time
equals zero so all these cosines just
become one cosine of zero is one so
these go away and we basically say you
know u of
x
at time zero
is equal to f of x
is equal to the sum
of n equals zero to infinity of c n
sine n pi over l x
and so that literally means that these c
n's are the fourier coefficients if i
fourier transformed my initial condition
f
so these cns are literally
f hat they're the fourier transform the
the discrete fourier transform
of this initial condition over that
domain zero to l
okay and if if you uh if that was a
little fast for you you can go back to
that video on separation of variables
for uh the heat equation or you could go
to my lecture on the discrete fourier
transform like this is literally the
definition
of the fourier transform where these
guys here
this is literally my
f hat fourier transform the fourier
transform of f these are my fourier
coefficients
of of f x
that's it that's that's the whole
story that's how you solve the wave
equation using separation of variables
it's actually quite quite simple you
assume that you can split your function
into a product of a function of space
and a function of time
you plug that into this partial
differential equation and take all the
derivatives and get you know a
relatively simple expression and collect
all the terms and x and all the terms in
time and because those equal each other
they have to equal a constant
and at this point we don't know what
this constant is it's just some some
constant k but then what you do is you
try to solve this ordinary differential
equation for just my spatial variables
you know f double prime x over f of x
equals some constant
and the only way that that can satisfy
my boundary conditions is if this
constant is a very very special number
pi over l times an integer the only way
that we can satisfy this boundary
condition is if lambda is pi over l
times an integer so those are my
eigenvalues of this
of this ordinary differential equation
or of this partial differential equation
the corresponding eigenfunctions
of this are these signs with that
wavenumber with that lambda wavenumber
in x
then you do the same thing for my
ordinary differential equation and time
now that i have determined what that
eigenvalue lambda has to be to satisfy
my boundary conditions i have to use
that same one for my ordinary
differential equation in time
so now i get these sines and cosines in
time
with a slightly different frequency
and when i combine those two solutions
when i take their product here and i add
them up for all integers n i get the
solution of my partial differential
equation
and what that means
physically
is that the solution of this partial
differential equation
i basically take my initial condition
and i you know decompose it into a bunch
of signs i take its fourier transform to
find out how
i can add up infinitely many signs
with you know period l
um
you know all of my signs with period l
and that determines this uh this
constant c
for my solution
and so then
each of those uh independent kind of
harmonic components each of those
independent sine waves we're literally
saying
uh you know if i have some
initial condition like maybe
maybe what i do is i pull up the guitar
string you know
with my finger and i make this little
triangle
that is equal to the sum of
uh you know this sine wave plus this
sine wave plus this sine wave and so on
and so forth this is the
n equals you know
one two
4 and so on and so forth
and and you know the coefficients cn are
given by the fourier transform of my
initial condition this is f x
then
each of these components these wave
components of my initial condition
oscillate at a different frequency so
this n equals one component oscillates
at a frequency n pi c over l
the n equals two oscillates at twice the
frequency n equals three at three times
the frequency and so on and so forth
and so essentially you know this this
vibrating guitar string is causing
pressure fluctuations in the air that
it's it's sitting inside of and that's
what's creating the acoustic waves that
are radiating away from this that you
can hear when someone plays the guitar
when someone plays the piano okay it
comes from literally
from this frequency here this is going
to be the frequency
of sound that you hear
is is this n pi c over l
and so now we actually see very clearly
and i'll pull out the guitar again for
this
is we knew that the wave speed depended
on things like the tension in the string
so you know if i increase the tension it
should increase the speed and so now we
know directly that increasing the
tension will increase the frequency of
acoustic waves because this is the
oscillation in time that's creating
those acoustic waves kind of how fast
this thing is flapping in time
is n pi c over l so increasing c
like increasing c by
having a smaller string
makes a higher pitch sound
increasing c by increasing the tension
[Music]
also increases the sound but the other
thing that could you know increase the
frequency uh the pitch of the sound you
hear is changing l
so if i make l
smaller if i cut l in half this
frequency frequency should double so if
i take my
my length and i pick the middle point of
the length i i think you can see this
the middle point here this is the 12th
fret
the middle point
[Music]
is twice the frequency
okay so changing l
you know if i if i cut l in half if i if
i pin this thing so it's half the length
it's going to be twice the frequency or
i could increase the tension by a factor
of i guess in this case uh
four if i made four times the tension in
the string it would double the frequency
or if i made it four times less dense if
i ever picked a material that was four
times less dense or i made it four times
smaller those would all have the same
effect of changing the frequency of the
sound
something else i think is kind of neat
is um
if you picture
you know i i'm literally like pulling
this guitar string up so it's a little
bit you know like a very very shallow
triangle when i pull it up and that's my
initial condition and then i let it go
you can picture the sum of all of these
waves oscillating
in time kind of the amplitudes are
oscillating in time
to generate
to generate that sound
and so if i just very lightly hold down
the string at just a random location
you hear that it's really damp you don't
hear anything that sounds
nice like a cord it just sounds damp
but there are some very special
locations
where some sound does come through
here's one
and i believe this is a third
harmonic it's a third of the length of
the string so you know some
of these
waves have a node a zero point at that
location
and so they are not affected by me
damping at that location and you can
hear this really really clearly if i put
my finger very lightly on the 12th fret
you can see that most of the sound is
coming through
[Music]
and it's a little bit higher pitched
that's because
all of the even ends n equals two n
equals four n equals six all of those
even ends are being able to to come
through even though even though i'm
damping i'm kind of like holding a
little bit of a damper at this point all
of the the even and sine waves are not
affected because they perfectly kind of
pass through that zero point where i'm
holding my finger
whereas if i pick a random location
and i
put my finger there i'm kind of killing
all of the waves and i'm killing all of
that sound
maybe this will make more sense if i
pick one string
[Music]
and it's twice the frequency n equals
two so
so that's kind of cool anyway this is
just uh
an example of how
you can get some intuition so i always
like to think about these these kind of
wave physics with an intuitive example
you could pick maxwell's equation you
could pick uh you know ripples on a lake
i like the guitar string because i think
it's very intuitive
uh how these sounds are being generated
you can put your finger in different
places to change l you can increase the
tension or decrease the tension you can
go to a string that has lower density or
higher density and all of those change
the frequency of the sound
good
um
yeah one last thing i want to show you
and this is going to end up being an
entire additional lecture so
i'm going to
very likely have a whole lecture on the
method of characteristics which is a
very very very important idea in these
this is called a hyperbolic partial
differential equation so this is a
hyperbolic
hyperbolic
pde
which basically means that there is a
speed of information propagation
uh in the in the problem because there's
a speed of sound
and for hyperbolic pdes there is
something called the method of
characteristics
method of characteristic
i believe this was also invented by
dalon bear
when he derived this this wave equation
i'm not 100 sure
um but i think so
and i'm going to have a whole whole
lecture on this but what i want to show
you is that
when you have
sine of something times cosine of
something you can use the
trig identity a really really simple
trig identity which is
sine of a
times cos of b
equals
one half
sine of a plus b
plus
sine of a minus b
this is just a trigonometric identity
you can verify this yourself but because
all of our solutions have the form sine
of something times cosine of something i
can essentially use those to write down
the following
essentially my solution is going to be
you know u of x and t
equals
i don't want to write this i'm going to
say this is equal to
the sum from n equals 0 to infinity
of that constant c n
divided by 2
times now i'm going to have a
sine of this
plus this
plus sine of this minus this
so that's sine
of
n
pi
over l
x
plus n pi over l c t so i'm just going
to say plus c t
and uh plus sine i'll just i'll go back
in and uh we'll double check that i
didn't mess anything up
n pi over l
and now it's this minus this so that's x
minus ct
and so this is really really really
interesting what this says is that
because of this trig identity sine of a
times cos b equals you know one half
sine a plus b plus sine of a minus b
i can take these
and you can verify for yourself that
you know n pi over l times x and n pi
over l times c t
give you this
expression when you use this trig
identity
what we find
is that essentially our solution u of x
and t is given by two these are called
waves
that are traveling in different
directions so x plus c t is a solution
that is traveling in one direction as
time increases this is kind of shifting
my solutions
uh i think this is shifting my solutions
if if time increases
then x has to be you know negative to
make this zero
and this other
part here is traveling in the other
direction so i'm just going to draw a
little picture here this is like a
teaser
for later and i'm going to have a whole
lecture on this method of
characteristics
is that if i have some initial condition
essentially i have information traveling
this is
x
and this is time so if i have a little
disturbance
that disturbance is going to travel
in the right direction and in the left
direction
because of these two
decompositions here so i'm going to have
a whole lecture going over the method of
characteristics which is how you can
take these wave equation solutions here
and you can write them in terms of these
uh kind of left and right traveling
waves that give you kind of this this
interesting um
behavior but i'll do that at a later a
later date
okay good um we have derived the wave
equation in the previous lecture in this
lecture we solved it using separation of
variables we tied that solution to some
physical intuition on a guitar string so
like literally what is the frequency of
sound you hear as a function of you know
the length of the string the tension the
material things like that
and we showed that using this trig
identity you can rewrite the solution in
this intriguing form here where i now
have this kind of interesting
anti-symmetric
left
traveling wave and right traveling wave
and so this is the basis of the method
of characteristics which
will be another lecture for another day
all right thank you